the joggin experience I also have
something else for you my man I can come
bearing gifts
yeah that's thing what the [ __ ] is that
dude this is called a Bushwhacker I
think something they use in the Congo no
no we'll get there what in the [ __ ] bro
so that is like I said be careful cuz
that thing is really sharp the weight
behind it I don't want you to cut
yourself okay that's like a giant wood
handle like you could double fist this
sucker yeah Mike Jones knife and tool
you actually have one it was nice yeah I
do and he made this because he is now
giving 5% of all of his knife sales to
fight for the Forgotten and he was
turned on to us through the show this
one's another one that he made my friend
Mike awkward Kim yeah that's that's what
he said wow it's got a built-in little
sharpener yep yeah that's that's a knife
or a fire starter it is yeah oh it's a
fire stick and it's a loose already
there
you use that tie over the top oh it's
also a bungee oh okay no a knife itself
super sharp its Damascus steel oh it's
pretty
and then that's his bow hunter style
knife mmm the wood is koa wood from
Hawaii so he thought you'd like that and
then he always has his little signature
smile yeah I follow him on the Instagram
yeah he's a great guy
yeah the other knife that Mike had made
for me is a bow hunter as well this is a
beautiful man thank you thanks Mike -
that's pretty man and there's one more
there from Mike Jones himself so he did
a thing called knife for the Forgotten
and he sold a hundred percent of his
knives for a fight for the Forgotten and
so that one's a chef's knife I thought
you'd really like the wooden handle is
actually black wood from Africa so it's
probably from Tanzania but it's a chef's
knife and he's got that smiley face in
there but it took him like 15 yeah I
knew how much you appreciate like
craftsman work so that took him 15 to 18
hours to make that that's pretty it's a
small handle - it's interesting
wow that's beautiful thanks man yeah man
oh you like it I'm not worthy well and
then that was just to set up this one
was this knife is what it was actually
all about but Mike said oh let me let me
throw in a knife or two because he
literally gives 5% of all his knifes is
this one of the ones that was made by
the pygmies that was made by King Zito
himself it was just some scrap metal
it's not the sharpest knife and he said
it wasn't the best for me to give to you
but I thought it was the most unique
that's his that's his actual kind of
signature design that he puts in there
it's so light yeah it's crazy what is
this wood so it's a wood that's out of
the simile key National Forest and
they've been collecting it for
generations which people can heal it how
light this is light feels like styrofoam
it's quite easy so they have these
different kind of like almost quirk
yeah feeling knives or handles please
tell him I said thank you
I will is very very nice of him in z/i t
oh wow that's so pretty
so yeah that's cool man I was able to
get you one of those that right and then
uh
Dustin Poirier one as well that's still
beautiful yeah
[Applause]